I'm Grant Imahara
along with wired brand lab and Mouser
electronics I'm traveling the world
exploring the ways people and companies
are using innovative technologies and
shaping Smarter Cities porto portugal a
beautiful old-world city facing new
world problems like congestion pollution
and a massive demand for data residents
here spend an average of 118 hours a
year in traffic it's frustrating
it kills productivity and results in
vehicles spewing too much co2 into the
atmosphere
luckily Porter was also home to a
company that could have a global
solution I was always intrigued by how
much data we could collect in the
physical world and bring to the Internet
and the friend of mine was working with
taxis and he said why don't you put
sensors on taxis and we'll pick up the
data that way and that's when I realized
we could actually build a mesh network
of connected vehicles that could cover a
city give more people internet access
but at the same time turn the vehicles
into mobile sensors that can gather
massive amounts of urban data what do we
have onboard this plush ozv nem
technology so there's a unit which is
right above the driver and is connecting
to all the access points around the city
and to the LTE network and creating this
mesh among all the vehicles and then
providing us an excellent Wi-Fi
experience so if you think of the bus as
a mobile sensor there are tons of things
that we could collect so you can collect
how bumpy the road is from the
accelerometer you can collect the air
temperature that's flowing outside you
can infer traffic patterns that can make
you plan better your routes as
so here in porto specifically at the
port
venya was implemented their technology
what we did was to install one board
units and then with Wi-Fi on the boards
they cannot check other graphic
situations in real time so what the city
gets is a level of visibility in
real-time information about the city
that is unprecedented how's that all
processed all this information is
collected transported to our network and
then gets warm up what drives me every
single day is to see the opportunity to
actually have a positive impact on the
lives of millions of people by enabling
cities to actually have mobility
services in vain iam we've just seen a
company that's innovating and using the
kind of products mowzer and its supplier
partners provide partners like analog
devices intel microchip technology and
molex to build a more open and connected
city next we're off to tokyo japan to
see new methods of farming that bring
the growing and cultivating of food
right into the heart of the world's most
populous city